foreign
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies a story we agree to tell each
other over and
you forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones in
House of the dragon video in this video
I want to go over what will happen at
the beginning of House of the dragon's
second season all of us recently saw
what happened in the season 1 finale
when rainer's son who carries valerion
died right outside of Storm's end in one
of the greatest scenes from this first
season a mod one eyes Dragon Veigar
devoured Lou carries and his Dragon
Iraq's above shipbreaker Bay this
shocking Revelation left renira
devastated in this event essentially
Begins the dance of the Dragons now that
blood has finally been shed No One Is
Safe And as we all know Rainier's other
son Jace is still out there with his
Dragon although Luke was the one who
died it was Jace who was thought to have
gone on the more dangerous Mission not
only is his flight much further but he
also has to stop at many different
houses along the way so in this video I
want to go over what happens when Jace
arrives at these houses in the vale
white Harbor and then Winterfell George
RR Martin has already confirmed we will
see how Stark in the second season of
House of the Dragon so let's see what he
has written in his novel Fire and Blood
this will be exactly what we will see at
the beginning of The Following season in
either the first or second episode it
says jacari's valerion descended upon
the Eerie on his young dragon for Max to
win the veil of Aaron for his mother the
maiden of the veil Lady Jane Aaron was 5
and 30 making her several decades older
than Jace never married Lady Jane had
reigned over the veil since the death of
her father and Elder Brothers at the
hands of the stone crows of the hills
when she was three now according to
mushroom this famous Maiden was actually
a Highborn Harlot with a ferocious
appetite for men and he gives us a
salacious tale of how she offers you
carries the allegiance of the veil if
only he could bring her to climax with
his mouth now septanus stay says this is
inaccurate Because he believes Lady Jane
Aaron actually likes women rather than
men when Jace arrives in the high Hall
of the Eerie lady game reveals how her
own family had tried to replace her on
three different occasions she said my
own cousin sir Arnold says that women
are too soft to roll I have him in one
of my sky cells if you would like to ask
him in this world of men we women must
band together and your mother remains
our rightful Queen the veil and its
Knight shall stand with her only if her
Grace will grant me one thing when
jacarius asked what that might be she
answered dragons I have no fear of
armies many and more have broken
themselves against my bloody gate but
you have descended on us from the sky as
visenya once did during aegon's Conquest
there was nothing I could do to stop you
I mislike that feeling send me dragon
riders in sojakari's valerion agreed and
Lady Jane knelt before him and bait her
Warriors to kneel and all swore their
swords then anjakari's sword North
across the fingers and the Waters of the
bite he lighted briefly at sisterton
where Lord Burrell and Lord Sunderland
also swore a legion to his mother then
he flew onto white Harbor where Lord
Desmond manderly met with him in his
merman's court here is where jacari's
valerion faced a much shrewter bargainer
white Harbor is not unsympathetic to
your mother's fight manderly declared my
own forebears were despoiled of their
Birthright when our enemies drove us
into Exile on these cold Northern Shores
when the Old King visited us long ago he
spoke of the wrong that had been done to
us and swore to make things right in
honor of that his grace offered the hand
of his daughter visera to my great grand
sire that our houses might be made as
one but the girl died and it was
forgotten Jace knew what this meant
before he left white Harbor an agreement
was drawn up and signed Lord manderley's
youngest daughter would be wed to Jace's
little brother Joffrey once the war was
over finally Vermax lifted into the sky
and flew jacaris off the Winterfell to
meet with its formidable young Lord
kriegen Stark he would later become
known as the old man of the north but
the Lord of winter fell was about 1-20
when jakaris came to him that year Lord
Krieg and Stark had come into His
lordship at the age of 13 after his
father Lord rickon Stark died roughly
eight years before this meeting now
during his minority his uncle Bernard
had ruled the north as Regent but when
Cregan became 16 years of age he found
his uncle Bernard to be slow to
surrender the north he was not so ready
to hand over the Reigns to his nephew
their relationship grew strained as the
young Lord became angry under the limits
his father's brother said on him finally
a few years later Craig and Stark rose
up and threw Bernard and his three sons
and cells then claimed the north for
himself soon after he wed lady era Nori
a beloved companion since childhood only
to have her die a few years later while
giving birth to their son in air who
Cregan named rickon after his own father
Autumn was well Advanced when Jace
arrived at Winterfell the Snows lay deep
on the ground a cold wind was howling
from the north as always and Lord Stark
was in the midst of getting everything
ready for the winner yet he still gave
Jace a warm welcome the snow and the ice
and the cold weather made Vermax uneasy
it is said so Jace did not linger long
amongst the northmen but many different
stories did come out of that short
Journey Grand maester Monken says that
Cregan and Jace took a liking to each
other for the boy reminded the Lord of
Winterfell of his own younger brother
who had died a decade earlier they drank
and hunted with each other and even
swore an oath of Brotherhood sealed in
blood now this seems more credible than
septinustasis version wherein Jakari
spends most of his visit attempting to
get Lord Cregan to give up his false
gods and accept worship of the seven
however we must look the mushroom to
find what other accounts omit his
account introduces a young maiden or a
wolf girl as he dubs her with the name
of Sarah snow so smitten was jakari's
with this creature a bastard daughter of
the late Lord rickon Stark that he lay
with her overnight on learning that his
guests had claimed the maidenhood of his
bastard sister Lord kriegen became most
Roth and only softened when Sarah snow
revealed that Jace would make her his
wife they had spoken their vows and
winterfell's own godswood before a
werewood and only then had she given
herself to him wrapped in Furs amidst
the Snows as the old gods looked on this
makes for a great story to be sure but
as with many of mushroom's fables it
seems more of a Fool's fevered
imaginings than of historical facts Jace
had already been set to wet his cousin
Bayless since he was four and from all
we know of his character it seems most
unlikely that he would break such a
solemn agreement to Shield the uncertain
virtue of some half-wild unwashed
Northern bastard if indeed there ever
lived a Sarah snow and if indeed
jacaries did dally with her that is no
more than what others have done before
and will do on the morrow but the talk
of marriage is ridiculous mushroom also
says that Jace's Dragon ver Max left
dragon eggs at one Winterfell which is
also thought to be absurd while it is a
fact that determining the sex of a
living dragon is difficult no other
source mentions Vermax laying so much as
a single egg so it must be assumed that
he was a male dragon this we do know
kriegen Stark and jacari's valerion
reached an understanding and they signed
and sealed an agreement that grand
maester Monken calls The Pact of Ice and
Fire like many others before it it was
sealed with a marriage Lord kriegen's
son rickon was a year old Jace was as
yet unmarried and childless but it was
assumed that he would sire children of
his own once his mother set the Iron
Throne under this new agreement Jace's
firstborn daughter would be sent North
at the age of seven to be fostered at
Winterfell until she was old enough to
marry Lord kriegen's Heir when jacari's
valerion took his Dragon back into the
cold Autumn Sky he did so with the
knowledge that he had won over three
major Lords in all of their bannermen
for his mother though his 15th name day
was still half a year away Jacob Aries
had shown himself to be a man in a
worthy heir to the Iron Throne had his
brother shorter and safer flight had
gone as well much Bloodshed in grief
might have well been avoided however we
all know what happened when Lou carries
and Amon left Storm's end now all of you
know what we should see happen at the
beginning of House of the dragon's
second season one of these scenarios
should unfold when jacaris arrives at
Winterfell when we finally see Hal Stark
again it will be very interesting to see
what option they go with will they have
Jace lay with their Sarah snow or will
we find out she never existed at all I
also really want to see if they will
have Vermax lay dragon eggs at
Winterfell this is something many fans
have been debating for years let me know
what all of you think down below now I
do want to say I'm sorry I haven't been
uploading many videos lately
unfortunately I did run into some real
life issues but things have finally
started to settle on the home front
moving forward my upload schedule should
go back to normal I still have a lot
more video setting your way as always I
want to thank all of you for showing
some love and holding me down I hope all
of you have a great day I will see you
again very soon
bye